- Welcome back to the Kelly Clarkson Show!
I'm your guest host Sunita Mani.
(crowd cheers)
Stepping in with my co-stars
from the new movie Spirited.
Will Ferrell, Octavia
Spencer, and Ryan Reynolds.
For people who don't know,
the film is a fun spin
on a Christmas carol,
but it's also a musical.
Ryan, this was your first musical.
Was it intimidating?
- Oh my God, it was so intimidating.
I mean, it was singing
and dancing and I, I don't
think I've ever felt pressure and anxiety
like that on a movie, in my life.
(crowd and costars laugh)
That was intense.
- Wow, you've done a lot of movies.
- That was... I've done a lot of movies
and that was nothing, that
was nothing like this.
We had dance, all of us had
dance camp for seven weeks.
Seven or eight weeks,
and then, but before that
months of tap dance training
and vocal training and all kinds of stuff.
So, I loved it 'cause I got insight into
what that world is like.
I'm a huge fan of, of musicals,
but I, I've never done one.
So, to have that privilege
to do this was pretty,
pretty exceptional. Yeah.
- Definitely.
Octavia.
- [Octavia] Yes?
- I have to ask, there's a
lot of dancing in this movie
and you've posted your
dance skills on Instagram.
- Oh, uh...
- [Will] Oh, I did?
- [Octavia] I, I, I did?
- [Ryan] Who me?
- [Sunita] Yeah.
(crowd cheers)
Oh yeah!
Oh, there it is and there you are.
- [Ryan] Oh yeah.
Love it.
- Yeah. We, we, uh, and that's what
I'm doing in the movie, guys.
- It's impressive.
- No.
- I mean did you have
formal training for that or?
- Not for that.
For that, that was, that
was my impromptu like,
- You're a natural.
- Ya know, crazy.
- [Will] Yeah.
- But
can I, can I just say, and not about me?
About, talk about...
Oh yeah. Yeah.
- [Ryan] Oh yeah.
- See, you could all do that.
- [Ryan] Crushin' it.
- Right?
She, you are amazing.
You're an amazing dancer.
- [Ryan] Born dancer right here,
- Thank you, thank you.
- [Ryan] And singer too.
- Guys, thanks.
I have a little dance in my background.
- Amazing.
- Thank you.
Will and Ryan, how would you rate your
dance skills in this movie?
- I, you know, we, well,
we tap, we had to tap,
which for both of us was terrifying.
- Right.
- I wouldn't say we
were like Fred Astaire.
We were... I would say more like
Fred Astaire's lesser known brothers,
Greg and Percy.
- Yeah.
- Greg And Percy, a lot
of people don't know this,
they were born without bones.
- [Sunita] I was a huge Percy fan.
- And they couldn't dance
- Couldn't dance at all.
But they taught Fred everything he knew.
- [Ryan] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- The tap was the most terrifying for me.
- Tap was, was terrifying.
The other thing, and it
sounds simplistic to say,
but it's hard to sing and
dance at the same time.
- At the same time.
- Because you practice dancing,
then you practice singing,
and then you're supposed to
combine them at some point.
And you forget that you
have to combine them.
- The worst.
- Last question to everybody.
Were you more comfortable
singing than dancing?
- I would say singing.
- Singing.
That part felt really good. Yeah.
- [Sunita] Yeah. Comes together.
- What do you think?
- You know, I, when you're
not used to any of it,
and you have a lot of eyes on you.
I, whenever I was in the recording booth,
I had to put myself in my shower.
And so I just basically sang
with my back towards the booth,
so that I could feel
totally alone, and sing out.
It's, it's not easy and,
and my hat is off to
all performers who, who do
it so effortlessly, you know?
It's, it's not my first, um,
uh, love
and I, I'm not terribly good at it, so...
- I, I I I'm with you, but I felt like
the singing was harder for me personally.
I, I think in our minds, we all have like
a five octave range.
And you're, you can just sort
of do anything, but then your
your, your mouth opens and
you push air through it
and you're like, oh God, that's
a, that's a little reedy.
(crowd and costars laugh)
So I struggled with, I
personally struggled with that.
- What about you?
- [Octavia And Ryan] Yeah, what about you?
- I, I think I was like
most comfortable singing and
in the studio with like, the
headphones on and being like
can we take that again?
- Yeah.
- I really enjoyed the, the kind of
the performance of being a singer.
- [Will] But dance is your
back, part of your background.
- I do have dance in my background,
so I was also very excited to,
to get to put that out there.
- Kind of show that off?
- A little bit. Yeah.
- You were a little cocky, during filming,
- I was a little cocky?
- I'm just gonna say.
- I don't remember it like that.
- To let you know that we
felt you acted cocky at times.
- We felt this was the right forum.
- Yeah.
- [Sunita] Oh no.
- To tell you,
- Oh, you were all so nice to me
and I was putting you
down that whole time.
- But this was the moment
where we thought we
should let you know our
true feelings about you,
you know, conceited.
- We got the shot, didn't we?
- You know what?
I have to say one thing.
One, the hard, the biggest
challenge for me, was I,
in all of our singing,
Will and I, for some reason
were face to face.
Like, they couldn't have us just
like facing different directions.
We were face to face.
You try singing for like
three weeks straight
while staring at Will Ferrell.
(everybody laughs)
It's like, who's like, you know, like,
he's like holding his ear for no reason.
And like I would, I would hit a note
and he'd look at me and go...
Again.
- Better. Better.
- Yeah.
It was so brutal.
- [Sunita] So funny.
You can actually hear me
laughing on the tracks.
I'm sure now.
Holding it back.
- You're all so wonderful
in it and you pull it off
and you sound amazing and look amazing.
- Thank you.
It's very... yeah
(crowd cheers)
The best.